Well, hello, everybody. We have a bunch of questions to get to. So welcome to another Zoom call. I have everybody muted.
And again, you can chat in your questions if you want.
And we will answer them.
Most people chat them in. Everybody's muted to begin with.
Alright, welcome to another Zoom call. Let's get going. Remember to look at our blog and our website.
We have questions so that you don't have to wait to the Zoom call or look at our patient membership site for your questions so that you don't have to wait for the Zoom call.
Hopefully, everybody's on the membership site. If you're not on the membership site, send me an email.
In poll cutters clinic. Everybody should have gotten the invite.
Yours might have gotten buried. Send me an email. And I will get you.
I'll get you another invite. So to you.
Alright, some questions. This is on the nega lace test. And I'm going to make a video about this. So I'm going to skip this question.
The person who asked this question actually said, this would be a good video question. I agree.
I will make a video on the nega lace.
Other question came in about using vitamin C and antibiotics. And they incited this research study using vitamin C and antibiotics.
I knew one to punch for knocking out of kids who stem cells.
Just remember I cannot and we cannot as a clinic recommend medication.
So you have to be careful with that just from a medical legal standpoint.
So certainly if this if this is something you want to try.
There is a group called caracology that uses different medications off label like that form and docs a cycloid as help with cancer as well.
We certainly don't recommend that it's the it's the only thing you do, but it is something else that you could do.
And you can look at their information and utilize that information. Of course, we can't prescribe.
The question will the zeolite. So this person is taking zeolite that they have.
It's not from us pull out other things. So zeolite is a key later. So what you're using a key later that you can absorb to getting across the gut wall and getting it to the bloodstream.
Yes, it will pull out other things key laders will key late heavy metals out of your body, but key laders also will key late things out like minerals.
Then you don't necessarily want to key later.
So understand that with using adding key later.
So if you use a key later and you're using pretty high dosage of it to try to get out heavy metals and things like that.
So you want to possibly think about adding some nutrients back in some minerals, especially sodium electrolytes and things.
Are there specific labs he should check if you do a full complete metabolic panel. It will test for a lot of your electrolytes that calcium and sodium and other some other just standard minerals.
And then to look at this person is talking about their brother who has brain cancer. So it's more unique than some of the other people that are on this call how much zeolite should he take that really depends on the product itself.
And you know it's not coming from us and we, you know, you're taking that out of your home, I will just tell you to take it according to the label of the product because otherwise, you might be.
You don't want to take too much of any key later over there to so you can overdose in a sense you can overdose on a key later.
If you take too much remember go back to the seven phases of detox book.
If you have not downloaded that's just a short little booklet.
It's a free download on this on the site if you haven't done that, make sure that you look at that you don't want to overwhelm your detox pathways.
You're in that with the perks I know reaction.
Also, whether why is cognition very so much by the hour and by the day is this common with glioblastoma mercury biotoxid toxicity. Yes, it's very common with any of those things individually, if you got all three of them that's even more so in issue so yes.
Also, I'm really concerned is a different person really concerned that my entire left breast, the area under my hand, including the nipple is very hard.
I could push on some of the areas and the indentations stay there for a minute or so.
And the breast is now about 1.2 times the size of the other is this something I should expect with the black sand process.
Well, it's not so much something that you should expect with the black sand process that's going to happen with anything so typically.
This is a person that has an open wound on their breasts exposing the cancer and they're choosing to use a topical black sand, which is a blood route paste that can kill cancer directly.
So the benefit of having a cancer come to the surface, whether it's a squamous cell cancer, whether it's a melanoma, whether it's a breast cancer that comes to the surface, the benefit of the cancer coming to the surface and breaking open the skin.
And that is that you can use topicals.
That's very scary thing for a lot of people, oh my gosh, the cancer broke open the skin and it's coming out of the body.
Yes, that's that can happen for multiple reasons, but it can be a benefit because now you can use topicals and by using topicals, you could kill more directly black sand blood route paste is a type of topical that you could use.
And it doesn't cause any pain to the area itself except for any stretching of the skin.
So when you use black sand on a melanoma on your arm, let's say you will stretch the skin as this cancer is drawing it out and that will be painful.
And you would use it on your breast, there's a lot less pain, not so much a need for any paid medications and you can kill directly the negative is, is that the cancer by this time is is obviously probably fairly large.
But it's fairly large, then there's a lot of drawing that has to take place so you may have to apply black sand, it may take multiple days to weeks for the first S card to come off.
And the cancer to come out and then you put black sand on again and it takes multiple days for it to draw out more deeper cancer and you might have to do this many, many times.
And one person I think is on their 14th draw and no signs of ending anytime soon so that's common with with breast cancer.
It's also common with melanoma, I had a patient with melanoma that did 13 times that he drew out cancer out his forearm that just kept drawing deeper kept drawing deeper kept drawing deeper his wound itself the scar itself never got any deeper.
But it kept drawing cancer cells that were deeper than the depth of his work.
And for sure he would be with us today if he did not do that so that was the states that had about five years ago, at least.
All right, I have done three flushes this person is talking about the gallbladder flushes three gallbladder flushes at the month of April and May.
First I saw very little stones and few hours later I released a lot of green pea size like balls floating.
Which were soft to touch Dr. Burg on his videos explaining that these green balls are not stones but bile released from the gallbladder.
I thought I had these successful flushes I had no idea that these are not stones well they are you are getting.
You are getting material out your gallbladder so don't be discouraged.
I would suggest if you have that that you should do another ultrasound of your gallbladder just to see what it looks like.
So typically if a person why would I do a gallbladder flush in the first place would be typically the person would have done.
Gall stone had symptoms of gallstones when did an ultrasound and on the ultrasound of their gallbladder shown a lot of stone formation in the gallbladder.
And then the recommendation for medical standpoint is to remove the gallbladder but that is typically not the best idea if you can tolerate tried to flush it out.
So if a person does gallbladder flushes you can get the gallbladder moving and get it flushed out.
I've had people having really bad gallbladder pain. It's very serious gallbladder pain.
Have had ultrasounds done showing the gallbladder just be packed full of stones and they just refuse to get surgery.
They did gallbladder flushes and it was just very, very difficult. I had one woman who did not have cancer but had other autoimmune issues.
I think she went through about nine months of gallbladder flushes until finally she really released all the stones so that she had a clean ultrasound on her gallbladder.
So it could take a long time but I would highly recommend that you get an ultrasound done to see exactly what's going on there.
So you may not need to chew a gallbladder flush. Most people don't need to do a gallbladder flush so you should only really be doing it if you have all stones.
There any non-estrogenic supplement that quells mild to moderate hot flashes.
And do you support supplementing with natural progesterone cream? So yeah, women who have estrogen ER or PR or her two positive cancers don't want to be taking progesterone with your PR positive don't want to be taking estrogen.
And typically you're getting those things through supplement so you can take so somebody who has going also going through a bit of pause is getting hot flashes wants to take a supplement that will help with hot flashes typically they're going to be an herbal that will stimulate some estrogen production.
And then the counter two tips on as well why would I want to do that if I have ER positive cancer. Well, there's understand that number one that just because you have ER positive cancer does not need that all estrogens are bad.
So it just means that the bad estrogens that one group of estrogens that tends to block the estrogen receptor in the on the cancer cell is the issue now typically from a medical standpoint, they're going to give you an aromatase inhibitor or other estrogen blocking drugs that are going to knock on all your estrogens sending you in to menopausal causing you to have lot flashes.
Well then the thought is well why would I take something that would stimulate estrogen production if there's there's some sense to that but there's also you have to understand it's not all estrogens are bad.
But so if you have ER positive cancer PR negative cancer you can take progesterone cream yes you can.
If you have ER positive cancer then you probably should avoid progesterone cream.
So if you have ER positive PR positive or her to positive and you the first the first supplement that you should choose if you have hot flashes in my mind is something that will stimulate a adrenal function.
So using adaptogens should be your first go to so using some adaptogenic herbs that will stimulate adrenal function and helps stimulate natural good estrogen production will might be the first thing to do.
And then if that still doesn't work then you can use try something like maca try something some of the other herbs the black co hash and other herbs that will help stimulate some estrogen function and balance your hormones.
But also try a if you're not post metaposal yet use it or variant tissue supplement to provide or variant tissue supplement that can help to so if if you're not ER or PR positive we have other people are taking progesterone cream.
My hammer bulb work just is effectively sitting next to me while I am sleepy rather than top of me yes it does yeah that's the only thing I would say it in others and questions about the ground heat if you're using a ground heat and it's up high on your bed.
It falls down next to you then you could be losing a lot of the frequencies right to the ground.
If you're not using a ground heat that's having it next to you is just as fine as having it over the top of you that's just fine I know that's get warm sometimes.
I'm wondering about specific hormonal support based on her monthly cycle so somebody actually wrote this question for another person she asked about doing a daily cheek swab and then sending them in all together for a K testing I suggested maybe doing a cheek swab once a week and send it in from check checking testing so let me explain this question a little bit what I think they're asking.
Your hormones especially a woman's hormones will fluctuate in a circadian rhythm on a monthly basis so your estrogen and progesterone are going to be different on day one then they're going to be day five.
So how do I know what supplements to be taking day one day two day three day for my cycle especially if you're using some hormonal nutrition.
This is a very difficult thing to ascertain for people because typically let's say even we're talking about like thyroid hormone.
A person has diagnosed with hypothyroidism or haxi modals it's typically based upon taking a blood test one time they have a high TSH low T4 to low T3 at a given time and then you're giving this person a medication to help stimulate to to supplement for this low thyroid and it could make the person feel a lot better.
The thyroid supplement is thyroid hormone also secreted in a circadian rhythm it's going to be different at four o'clock in the afternoon than it is at nine o'clock in the morning.
So taking a blood test of a hormone and then saying this is how much you need is like I've always said it's like taking a photograph of a moving trade and then asking somebody how fast is the trade moving.
There's no way to tell you do you have a still picture so that's the way it is with hormones so do you need a test for hormones is is is inaccurate at best so there are some labs out there that will do a monthly cycle hormone test where you do a saliva test every single day and it's measured and you basically are mapping out your period you're mapping out your cycle.
So they're measuring the progesterone estrogen levels testosterone levels and your cortisol levels on a daily basis and they're looking at I think you actually take it every three days or some three or every two days so you get like 15 little vials that you do a saliva sample with and you do this for 15 days of your 30 day total cycle.
And it gives you a really nice map there's multiple labs that do that it makes it much more accurate but still then how do you know how many supplements to take if you're supplemented for that that because very difficult when I see a lot of thyroid patients my my suggestion for them was let's just we look at the blood work to see if we're in a fairly good range but then how you're going to dose yourself.
Is it going to be based you have to be based partly if not mainly on your symptoms if you're feeling really sluggish today your thyroid's pretty probably pretty low and you maybe need to add some more supplements you know a little bit extra supplements for your thyroid so you're feeling a little anxious and your heart is a little bit jumpy and racy then you've got to back down on your thyroid supplements you have to do it that way.
I had hundreds of thyroid patients throughout the years and that was the best way to do it they had to play with their dosage like that this is the advantage of doing some of your own tested and sway tested and trying to get good at that and and played with your dosage like that there isn't a perfect way to do that.
This person developed a new rash since starting the new right frequencies please advise I don't think the new rash hasn't do with the right frequencies because of a couple of reasons I'll tell you you can get a rash from running a right program because maybe your detoxing and your liver is is overloaded and you could just be detoxing through your skin so that is possible with these free.
frequencies that I said to you so that is possible what could be done for rashes like to support a detox process well that's great question because that's their totally thinking correctly here is there a detox rash protocol really when you if you have a rash because you're detoxing you need to support your liver so really you need to get going to coffee animals get going to Castro packs over your liver make sure you're having you know
one to three bowel movements a day make sure you're getting rid of all your toxins that's what you need to start go back to the seven phases of detox book and and just walk through that you can do I had pro waves you can do try to support detoxing through your skin through through doing solace so that would be a great thing to add is solace to this.
make sure you're doing your eye to other person asking a question for someone else the tumor site under ankle has gotten really painful and large.
Okay, this one we actually is a whole question we have this last time all right so people have said in questions I'm up by updated right program came thank you and it is different I used to have 16 night programs and no short day programs.
Yep so remember I said it's different my new program has one set of night programs and two short day programs so remember on your day programs it doesn't mean you have to do them I gave you some day programs to do if you have time so let's say oh goodness my day is so busy I don't have time to do the day programs well then don't do that's okay but the day programs are there like I want to sit down and watch TV and I am right here what should I run then run the day programs.
So by bulb still gets hot yeah well I do not have a concern that the bulb getting hot however should I be concerned that everyone else is so different with this update yeah because your program is different but I did make everybody's everybody's program is one week so that's
that's was just I just wanted to get back to everybody getting more of their cancer frequencies in their program this is much more precise program so yeah you did receive the correct thanks for the question.
H-bond can that be done at any point in the chemo protocol or should it not be done with their ask it is in the chemo protocol should you not do hyper rare oxygen in that 48 hour window I don't see I don't see any problem of doing it in the 40 hour I think you can do it anytime I might be wrong but I cannot think of any negatives to do it.
In H-bond continue to do it daily Dr. Connors is there one specific thing that we can be trained for you this week thank you well that's very very kind of you just for rest that would be nice then if you were to give my voice back that would be nice too thank you.
If that meant is all one 100 or 222 milligram per day is taken for three days on four days off when and what test can be used to see if it is working or to adjust so you would we would test with a cheek swab if if this is what we recommended for you and we would recommend the frequency of what we're doing.
If this is something that you're just doing on your own how do you know any cancer protocol is working you go back to the tests that we talked about so that would be you know whether it's a CT scan or MRI or PET scan or to a marker test or whatever you're using to judge your care whether we're going to the right direction of that.
What do you think of using drip IV drip therapy IV therapy NAD so with NAD you have to be really really careful because people can have really bad reactions to it so NAD I be really came out to help with people that are addicts so they're addicted to typically was used for drug addiction.
And you can have really bad reactions to it so I would be careful with it when it first came out it wasn't even legal in the US and people were flying to Mexico to get it and it was very helpful for people who were addicted to narcotics and different things I do a couple people patients that actually went and did that.
But I would say no to that I would be very careful with that because you can have really bad reactions you can even have bad reactions is taking NAD so just be careful with that.
Program I have for my right is typically nine hours and I often only sleep for eight hours should I pause nope just just get up and you could either let it time out I usually never turn it off I just said I'm ready to time out and it will just shut off when it's done otherwise if you're going to get up and you're not going to lay down again just turn the machine off that's a better thing to do properly.
What is the one hour 38 minutes of short program frequency is it a general cancer program I'd have to look and see what I did for you I'd have to look it back and see what I did for you because I need to take beta one 3d this is beta blue can but I checked in your store and it is sold out.
So we have several different brands of beta blue kid.
If you're looking at the one brand with the blue label I don't know that we have that I could actually look at the store really quick.
We just came up with a brand new beta blue kid.
That i'm really excited about so you should look at that.
Beta blue kid the one that's the beta one 3d is from that brand is sold out.
If this is something we tested you on I need to recheck you to see if this new beta sign from us and Simon work it's supposed to be so much more potent you need less capsules i'm excited about that because it's always hard to take it a bunch of stuff.
And again the US enzymes above every other company we have even is the clearest most in order to company in the world I know the order personally and know the reps very well that are just really add on the cleanse the cleanness of the product purity of the product is what I think you know.
So I would suggest that if this is something that we tested my hemoglobin numbers have been rising but my platelets platelets are dropping why would this happen.
And are there things foods that I can do to target my platelets.
For your hemoglobin and your platelets one of the things that can be good is beats another thing that can be good for this is spleen.
Which of course you don't eat spleen but spleen extract tissue and the only company that I know that has that is biotics research that can be beneficial for that.
Your platelets if your platelets are really low, there is another product that we have from.
From Jensky that is the the immutable pro from bell Jensky that's really expensive so we can do with other things it will be better that's the thing that's been shown to increase platelets that's really a pricey product.
So we don't try not to push that if we can help it.
What are your feelings regarding hydrogen water specifically looking at the echo from synergy science hydrogen water has a lot of promise that makes sense for a biochemical standpoint it makes sense for a physiology standpoint you can also use a hydrogen machine that are out there.
I tested one of those in a seminar I was at a few years ago it hooks up it's just sits on your desktop hooks up to your body with a nasal cannula and you sit there and breathe in hydrogen.
And your the absorption rate is very good across your your alveolar space and your lungs that could be very beneficial.
It's something that I think I wrote a couple of blog posts about it a long time ago.
It's has a lot of promise.
I don't know that I know the number of patients that have used it and no number of doctors that have used it.
And like me I was really super excited about it. We have an echo system. But I don't use it. And I just it's something that has a lot of promise, but I don't know that it's actually showed the promise that it has.
So I'm not I don't I don't want to say it's a negative about it, but we don't even use ours. So can THC oil be taken at the same time as low dose L.D.
So L.D. is low dose, no dose, no dose is typically used. It's a medication typically use for autoimmune issues because it can be an immune balancer or what's called T reg cell stimulator.
It stimulates your T regulatory cells, which can help balance a hyperactive TH water hyperactive TH two side. It's very good with autoimmune issues and there's been some promise with its use for cancer.
I do not know of any contraindication of taking THC oil or Rick Simpson oil, if that's what you're talking about with L the end, I don't know, I don't know of any contraindications.
We don't use L the end that's a prescription. A product what I used to see a lot of autoimmune patients, I used to recommend that they get L the end from a company pharmacy. We don't, it just never tested well for cancer patients. So I actually stopped carrying are you familiar with the methyl blue product protocol used with red light therapy for cancer treatment. I am not.
I don't know about that, so I'd have to look into that.
What would be a few good daptogenic herbs to try for hot flashes.
I would look let me step back here a second.
So adaptogens again, adaptogenic herbs are herbs that can balance your hormones. If they're too high, it can bring them down if they're too low, it can bring them up.
So that's why they're called adaptogenic helps you adapt to your environment and helps balance your body and your hormones.
I think we carry about six adaptogens. One of my favorite is the product new adapt from orthomolecular. The reason why I like that is it has some things that can help call your brain as well, which again, that's what controls everything right is your brain.
So new adapt is a great herb to start with, probably the most.
Our highest sales of adaptogenic herbs is premier research labs adaptogen R3.
That's a very clean product, a very good product.
True adapt is another adaptogenic product by orthomolecular and that might be even better for hot flashes.
So there's there's just some little bit different combinations of those. But if, if you're having hot flashes, I think I'd probably go with the true with the true adapt.
TRU AD APT by orthomolecular and I would try it for a couple of weeks, I try it for a bottle.
Let's start with taking one a day and then after a couple of days to go to go to two a day after three a day, you can, the nice thing about adaptogenic herbs, you really can't full deal them.
So, especially if you just kind of tight trade up and down what liver supplements are helpful to take.
Well, go back to my book, the seven phases of detox and the detox that this out of the seven phases phase one two and three are really talking about the liver and they give you some options of supplements to help support phase one phase two, phase three.
And there's other things that just help liver cells themselves like co q 10 and and some bovine liver support that are specific to detox pathways.
But if you're talking about helping with the liver detoxification pathways, look at that book on a list of different supplements.
There's a difference between the hammer bulb and the double bubble I have the older right I use the hammer bulb at night in the double bubble during the day.
I cover the hammer bulb at night, I assume coverage is okay as the light bothers him, so this is persons using it for her son.
Double bubble is going to be stronger if you have it right up next to your body.
So, the beauty of the hammer bulb is that it's easy to put next to your bottle body because you can stuggle with it and cuddle with it.
We recommend and we sell the crystallized hammer bulb with all our patients, so I don't know if you have the crystallized hammer bulb or just the regular hammer bulb.
And if you don't have the crystallized I'd say to stay with what you got the double bubble theoretically and it is stronger if it's really close to you.
The negative is is that you can get some little shocks if it's touching you, but it's nothing that's going to hurt you it's it's good for you.
So, when we used to have people come into the clinic we use the double bubble because it's just the way we had it set up by the stand.
It does become cumbersome you can break those things you know you have the little microphone stand for it can become clumsy so there's some negatives to the double bubble.
But it is stronger of a bulb, especially if you're going to be you know have it be away from you during the day and you're kind of walking around and you're come up next to it.
It's going to go farther distance so that would be the advantage.
And if you're just going to be sitting there in the and you're in the if you're not moving and you're just using the double bubble on you you might still just have the hammer ball.
You only need enough strength for penetrate your body anything else is just wasted.
So the whole claim to fame about strength with like the gb 4000 stronger than the true right I do agree it is stronger than the true right but how much strength do you need you just need enough strength to get through your body.
So the gb 4000 you can measure out 20 feet the right you can only measure out you know 8 to 10 feet.
Well if you're thinking you're going to be right feed during the day and be 20 feet away from the gb 4000 I think you're going to actually get.
Healthful benefits from those frequencies you're fooling yourself so you just need the strength for it to penetrate the body.
You think of hyperbaric chambers to fight the cancer so we talked about that in another question hyperbaric is a great therapy most of the research of hyperbaric cancer have to do brain cancer.
But hyperbaric forces oxygen in your tissues anytime you can do that can is a benefit hyperbaric is fantastic for any cognitive issues cognitive loss early dementia issues to help ward off early dementia Parkinson's Alzheimer's type things.
hyperbaric is great and just for a healthy thing for cancer the only problem I have with hyperbaric is that typical that literally all the studies are doing it daily and that can become just a just a problem you know to be able to get to someplace that has a hyperbaric chamber.
If you can afford to buy your own hyperbaric chamber at your house had you could do it daily or even three times a week.
You will probably notice the difference just in your clarity of thought there could be a lot of benefits to it.
So it has been your experience with DCA DCA is a product that typically you're taking with with MCG on GAF and in GCM AF and it's and it was typically used together but now you know people are using it separately we've had patients use GCMF and DCA over the years.
Our experience has been very mixed when like we talked about it's another question that I said I'm going to make a video about when GCMF first came out we saw we saw much better results.
The newer form of GCMF we just haven't seen really any good results with patients but that doesn't really don't exist I'm just saying my experience with that.
Could you recommend IV infusion of high dose vitamin C that's when we do the testing if that comes up positive we do make that recommendation.
And we do have a number of people that are doing that so that doesn't come up positive in our testing that I don't recommend it.
But some people are still doing it and that's fine too so that's a choice everybody has to make there's some negatives to these things too.
The patient in the hospital for two weeks because they were doing IV vitamin C and it caused a lot of swelling and she's convinced it was from the IV vitamin C that's not something we tested positive for but it's something they chose to do.
And so there's some negatives you got to be careful with doing that too.
So what about the home version of the hyperbaric chamber I think the home units are fantastic they're great units they're expensive but you can get a great hyperbaric chamber to use at home and do it every day typically you do it for an hour.
And it's you know you're used to getting in there sealing it up turn it on it's it's pretty easy to do yourself you don't even need anybody at home to help you as long as you could get it in an out of it.
I can't do them because of my side issues but if you know some people can't do it because of claustrophobia too you have to I suggest you try it before you go buy one.
Or try a unit somewhere I know that oxy health has home units that they read to sell so you they're read to old those I think are the best units there's other companies out there that have good units they're a little bit thinner material oxy health I think will last you longer they're going to have less problems there a little more quality.
Cheek swab test for ivy run and see for a patient yes we do test for that so if you didn't have that under your recommendation it didn't test positive right right thank you guys we will bid a do for the evening.
We have a lot of you much experience with cell core products we do we use cell core products a lot and they can be great key layers great binders that's really what they're known for as a company.
For sure all right remember to ask your questions through the patient portal your membership site if you can it was the lot of you are doing that most of you are doing that now and we'll have this video god willing up on the site as well.
Thanks for everybody for attending and quick another quick question about quick silver quick silver products are great products to very good products very good company.